if you knew that 90 of your business
was how to do pictures and videos on
facebook
you would act differently every day this
portion is like with me so i think this
is when you need to get selfish
like you need to ask your question
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast
that's how you get [ __ ] done that's how
you figure stuff out this
is the television and the television
is the radio the 40s
[ __ ] there he is hey gary
hey hey everyone how are you son
hi hi gary hey everybody sorry about the
confusion i had some wrong links
i have a board meeting at one o'clock so
i'm going to go right into it
um would love to you know joke you want
you take the lead and just pick on
someone please say hello
uh where uh where you're from and then
go right into uh your actually let's do
intros first because it's good context
for me
so joe if you could just yeah so let's
uh let's start with jason williams the
birthday boy
jason uh you're up uh tell gary who you
are
i gary uh jason williams uh from jack
williams tire company so
we're a third generation family business
91 years old
and just recently launched the new uh
disruptive concept of mobile tire
installation
so we have 36 traditional brick and
mortar stores
a whole new brand that we're launching
and just trying to
launch a new model out there that's
awesome
i get it get right back to you jason uh
gary let's go down to
daniel and michael juha in honduras
uh you her brother say hello hey how's
it going gary uh very happy to be
here um we have we own a um
family business as well of 50 years um
we're a hardware store we're into
wholesale retail
franchise and e-commerce as well both
for retail and for uh
b2b awesome real nice to meet you
michael nice to meet you toby
over in barbados say hello to gary
what's happening gary nice to see you
man
good to see you good man we got two
retail stores building the third store
we've got e-commerce presence also
um we are selling high-end power tools
and equipment
to barbados the country barbados to the
b2b
or to the consumers of barbados of both
b2b and b to c
thank you let's keep the outside of the
continental u.s flare going in
uh hawaii
hey gary hi gary zach and courtney here
um we're sage creamery we're saying
thank you i remember all the whole thing
it's good to see you guys again i'll be
ready
okay thank you let's swing back
into the united states but uh let's go
down to florida
geo and antonio from stream media say
hello to gary
you're on mute or we can't hear your
audio guys can hear you
uh how you doing uh this is gio and
antonio
from stream media so we're the most
innovative
and interactive ott streaming platform
in the world
so we work with content providers to
provide our technology so they can build
the next generation netflix spotify
ott direct to consumer solutions so
obviously
our our business is booming we're
launching two new products uh direct to
consumer
and we love to hear you know what you
think awesome thank you
ryan uh working our way up the coast
ryan smith in georgia say hello to gary
hey gary how are you doing
um i'm doing very well how are you i'm
doing well thank you
thanks for allowing me to be here i also
wanted to
wish you a slightly late happy birthday
um
i i believe that you're not even close
to halftime yet so just keep doing it
thank you um so i have a very small
startup
uh home theater design company that my
wife and i are trying to build so that
way i can get out of
the job that i'm not very happy doing
and uh
i'm just thankful to be here and
learning everything that i can from
from you guys thank you so much and
lauren martin from uh
franklin tennessee who's got a
burgeoning business
uh in the field of therapy go ahead and
say hi to gary
hi gary i think you'd like my shirt it
says practice radical empathy
love nice um so i am here because i want
to go from being a therapist in the
chair to developing products
digital products for clients what i want
to launch next year is the idea of a
solo self-guided retreat
where you have videos pdfs
guided prompts for the day so that you
have the retreat experience but on your
own
friendly awesome and uh christopher
up in uh milwaukee uh go ahead and say
hi to gary
hey gary how you doing grant really
happy to be here um so i have a medical
practice but i tree foot and ankle
a single location scaled it down um to
scale it up so
sold a couple of my offices and i want
to scale it up i have a great location
and then i coach and consult with
podiatrists i want to be able to scale
up use digital just really get better at
doing that
and then be able to coach other people
to do it as well
i understand and finally we're going to
bring it home
uh with esther who's the closest to you
gary she's in the tri-state esther say
hi to gary
hi gary how are you good morning or good
afternoon i'm not going to waste time i
think gary knows that i have all the
contacts
thank you so much thank you so much all
right let's go back around the horn
jason fire away and and team
this is where you go very narrow with
your question obviously
the 4ds program will give you a ton of
context but i want you to go very narrow
and what we've learned through the years
is
a lot of times it helps everybody else
too from a different angle so it's
exciting but be selfish
go narrow okay uh so
launching a new uh disruptive brand uh
so a disruptive model as well as a brand
so people
were having some challenges just
connecting a van coming to your house to
change your tires versus
for the last 90 years going to a brick
and mortar so trying to figure out how
we could
um be more strategic in
driving appointments so there's a
certain number of appointments that we
need to do each day
per van as well as um
are they your own operated and known
vans yes
yes yeah so so we have those they're all
they're in different how much first
party data do you have on prior
customers through the years
um well we're trying not to target our
traditional customers
so we're we're looking for new customers
in the market
i think that might be a mistake which is
why i'm asking the question
let me freeze i think you should 100
target
new customers uh the
to back to the question brother do you
have the information of all your
customers through the years
uh yes yes yes we could get it we were
changing systems recently but uh yeah
but you would you would have email at
least
yes address yes i would
uncover is the number one mistake people
make when they go to a new format for
their service
is literally what you walked into which
is like this is not going to be the same
customers these are people that don't
want to come they're going to be younger
it's the cliche mistake the
you have to market in two ways in
parallel
but your your historical client rick
58 years old in pittsburgh that walked
into your store
six years ago and has never come back
but the data sits in one of your old
systems
is the first person i'm sending a direct
mail piece to and an email
okay lapsed users from the old model
because you're sitting on the data
you know that they would even consider
what you do
right the money you're going to spend
trying to get all of us
i would never do what you do i've leased
all my car i don't even think like i
don't think i've changed my oil in any
car
in my 27 years of ownership or tires or
any like
no shot you can spend a billion [ __ ]
dollars you tell me about the jets
you can talk me about wine it's not
happening you're sitting on a gold mine
of data of people that would consider it
and don't think that
you know james orsini how old are you
57. beautiful don't assume that james
just because he's 57 doesn't value his
time
and wouldn't love for you to come to his
[ __ ] house instead of him going away
tires this week got ripped off told had
to
run flats for that small mercedes my
daughter drives rip me off
so jason to that point i think you st so
to plan attack
for every this is going to matter for
everybody for for streaming for gio and
antonio
for all of you ice cream whoever's best
at spending the least amount of money
running ads and making pictures and
videos to get people to consider their
business
will win that's it
that's it nothing else that's all i've
done for
25 years right that's why i like tick
tock that's why i like linkedin right
now that's why i like
creators and pcs's and every single
thing that comes out of my mouth
now bucketing your two groups
into historical clients and new clients
is where you have to go
i'll give you a couple tidbits you ha
you have to master facebook creative and
media
facebook not facebook inc not instagram
yes instagram but for your business to
work for the math to work on what your
overhead is on your own
vans you're gonna your company is gonna
need to be have to be great
at facebook because it's this most
scaled
cheapest and in the pocket of the age
group
that i think you will convert best on
your product
for for zach and courtney it's instagram
for you it's facebook for zach and
courtney it's instagram story ads that
swipe up
to their dtc or their store they'll run
it different hawaii because it's come to
the store
as they will with shipping got it so
there's nuances within it
for you pictures and videos now when
you're doing a new thing
doing videos on your phone even that are
a little silly and a little different
you need to teach people that it's cool
for people to come to their house
so the creative the things you know
there's a mil
as all of you know there's millions of
people on the internet
that try to be like garyvee right
there's a lot of people talking about
business advice motivation content
social
it becomes a game of who's best
so not only and i'm talking about in the
content
so the tire it's insane how the world
works today now
the business is imperative you have to
have a good business a good product
getting ripped but but james just got
ripped off right
it's why he considered that business did
it show up first on google did he say
that
was it word of mouth from somebody one
of the reasons i want you to hit up all
your current clients
is for the eight percent of them that
take you up on this new service
they're going to be the loudest people
at dinner tables talking about your
service
hey jane once we get back from covet hey
jane you know what i did this week it's
crazy
you know jack like they came to my house
got it yeah i guess
so that's a follow-up so the other part
is entering new markets and we're also
moving to franchising the concept as
well
right so if you look at all the mobile
fitness stuff and the other stuff that
you're probably
looking at for this model junk and all
that stuff
it's the same game brother like you have
to have a massive marketing strategy to
build awareness in a marketplace
and you have to create awareness for
your brand so that franchisees come in
you know i'm sitting on the my in 40
minutes which is why i'm going to
should come through by the way anybody
who i miss we're going to schedule some
five and 10 minute versions of this
because i'm not going to let you down so
don't stress as the time goes on here
um uh the other thing to think about is
the recruitment my board meeting at one
o'clock is bojangles
the you know chicken restaurant down in
the carolinas i know
i'm leading up the task force to do
content on linkedin to get franchisees
so it brother and i'm telling you this
is why i'm staying on this one because
this is the answer to ev
literally to everybody there's nothing
even close to as important as knowing
how to run media on social media
and how to make content that works on
social media there's nothing
even close left
so you know you can acquire franchisees
with a crazy linkedin strategy because
you're making content about
entrepreneurs that don't want to take
the full risk
get it right you're gonna you know
you're gonna have to own facebook
because you can target people 48 to 57
right who are car enthusiasts who also
like the steelers and in that video
you're talking about
remember the bus jerome bettis well
we're like the you know we bring the bus
to like you see where i'm going
yeah and then that video goes well and
you're like wait a minute maybe we
should reach out to general medicine
sure enough
jerome bettis is a washed up athlete
let's call it what it is and he'll for
ten thousand dollars be in your videos
and now you're convert like this is a
forever living and breathing machine
hey everybody yeah go ahead joe i was
gonna say we uh
in in respect to time we should probably
move on please good job thank you
thank you for executing on what i told
you to do when i went in here no problem
why don't we go
keep in the same order why don't we go
down to uh honduras and talk to the uh
brothers uh
uh daniel uh or michael want to chime in
and ask gary your question
all right thank you hi gary um so
actually that bit about franchising was
really helpful for us we're involved in
that space as well
um well i don't know how many times a
day you get this but i dropped out of
college because of you
it was last year and um
were parents upset with me no actually
they were the only ones who
who supported me so everyone else told
me not to do it you know that's
really yeah reminds me not to do it yeah
yeah remember remind your brother and
everybody else you can always go back
yeah yeah i do i do i'm not going i get
it um
so so basically since last year we
started this franchise concept
and you know my brother we and i we've
lived in the states i've lived in europe
and so we've seen
all these different businesses out there
you know the whole environment there
and when we come back here it's like we
we want so many things to change
um so really we're set out on this
mission to make make
something uh make sort of this vehicle
that will allow us to
um go into other businesses you know
we've we've been focusing hardware all
our lives our families have been
so we're trying to branch out and get
into other things you know um
uh b2b ecommerce uh platform services
consulting
retail infrastructure so yeah we we're
sort we're
interested in your experience as vaynerx
you know this machine that you've
built uh and the idea of how much time
do we spend
operating versus managing a business you
know i'm i'm a
i'm a programmer so how do i like how do
i balance my time in
building a platform versus managing
everything around it
patience
right i mean you know it was seven years
of white vaynermedia before there was
an m a activity you know so patience
uh putting in the work based on your
ambition
so you know i don't know you two and i
don't want you to burn out but if you
have this big ambition
because i operate and manage
and i'm garyvee right and so
so what i why i say that is
i want to know what your 24 hours look
like
i really do now now if you have patience
you don't have to burn out right
you know but the way you manage it is
more time like i work
for example every day during covet like
i'm basically at 14 hours
every minute no lunch no dinner in front
of the computer
you know really you know 8 a.m to 9 p.m
like just
right there 12 13 14. every minute
that's a lot of output in one day that's
13 14 hours
of work you know a lot of people who
have big ambitions
when they really audit it they did this
for an hour in the middle of the day
they took care of this personal matter
like how many hours
of output and then if your ambition is
big
because you're talking big is you're
both so young
and before you say anything daniel
you're so young so you're both so young
that it's okay to be eight hours but you
just need to know
that that's gonna then take 14 years
yeah it's net hours i i think we
understand the
the patient the patient's component and
you know there's just so much that we
want to get done and
and i know we have to be patient i want
to do so much too
i think you do one at a time you know
whenever you go into your
so for example the first thing you do
outside the thing you've always known
you need to be focused on that for many
years
you know because don't forget my
expansion wasn't something completely
different they were all in the same
basic realm
the gallery media group is talking to
the same customers at vaynermedia
sasha is just part of the garyvee
ecosystem and vaynermedia because
it's all just kind of connected so it's
not like
you know for example even though i
successfully did rezzy
and i successfully did um empathy wines
i wasn't able to impact those businesses
the way i'm impacting this
so the second they become too different
it's almost like a whole
i did like an overlap not like a
separate
got it yeah yeah keep that in mind
yeah i have a another quick question
about franchise we launched our
franchise business
five days before we we got into a
quarantine
which was back in march and now we've
been
hit by a hurricane two weeks ago and hit
by another one this week
so it's kind of tough you know getting
new franchisees you know
asking people to invest 100k 80k into
you know new retail stores
do you have it franchisees we have uh no
we have uh
our model store was launched in march
and then we got into quarantine so
we have a bunch of leads but people just
don't feel like investing
and you know i think you've got timing i
think you should build community right
now
okay and linkedin things and just build
relationships and don't even ask to
close
call it franchise advisory sessions okay
and you start off with like like we're
here to just talk about it in the macro
business in the macro marketing in the
macro franchise season got it build
relationships yeah because people
people yeah people love the business
that they just don't want to close right
now people are talking 2021 and
so we just need to have patience as you
say you know 100 percent
on that theme um gary toby has been down
and he's a brit hanging out down in
barbados he's been there for 13 years
he's in a similar uh industry to the uh
brothers but toby why don't you go ahead
and fire up a question uh to garyvee
yes great um gary my first question
would be um
we've been doing unique content every
day so we will push
365 a year unique pieces of content
every piece of content we've done it
it doesn't have a face in it do you
think that we should be putting a face
in it to scour the
business i don't think you have to
i don't think you have to i think you
should you could consider it i think
if you know there's two ways of faces
there's usain bolt or there's garyvee
are you saying yourself and your team or
are you saying
other people that you rent equity from
like a famous
barbados influencer it could be either
but because of
when it gets technical with product it
might have to be an internal face
i think you should do that because
people trust humans
so i think i would i would do it but i
don't think you have to
okay does that make sense yeah yeah for
sure the only slight
nervousness on it is um being obviously
a white englishman
in her in a different environment which
is 95 percent dark pigmentation
and different local mindsets
and you know i think that's a great call
out do you feel like
the market would be overly now one of
the things you could do it is with a
co-host
maybe it's you and okay
somebody internal or maybe it's always
for people it's like a round table
discussion
on the content so maybe it's
two internal one external former client
current client
somebody else that's in the space so you
can make the format less about one
person and more about
several okay cool that's great
um can i fire a quick a few quick
questions one um
talk about marketing i'm not hurting on
a lot of content but
would you ever recommend what sort of
marketing percent of revenue you would
spend on uh marketing and budget
me personally every dollar i can afford
okay i believe in it i believe marketing
is more important than money
because you'll get the return or
confident of getting a return
yeah because i don't because i don't
think if you're not marketing digitally
today
you're actually going to go out of
business understood
like over time it's just going to
corrode
so i think the stakes are higher than
people realize
okay changing the genre a little bit
how would you motivate an employee
that's not motivate
motivated by money by giving them what
they're motivated by
my i this is a huge mistake that
business owner makes
people are motivated by different things
and if that person's motivated by
a three-day weekend on fridays you have
to consider it
now if you're scared that sets a
precedent for other people you can just
speak to them and say
let's just use people in here ryan comes
to you and says hey why
zach and jason off on fridays and i'm
[ __ ] working here and i say
ryan they're taking less money to be off
on friday
if you want to take a 20 cut on your
salary you can have friday off
understood yeah
it really works this was something my
father couldn't understand he thinks
everyone should be motivated by money i
think because he was
he thought everybody should work as hard
as him and i was like they work for you
it's not their business and he was very
inflexible
he thought they should be motivated by
what he wanted them to be motivated by
i have a very very reverse model to that
cool
is there is there any lifestyle habits
that helped you become successful
the ability not to judge myself the
mental lifestyle aspect of understanding
i'm human
i'm far from perfect i have good intent
i have to be patient
i like people i'm in business which
means
a lot of times it's not going to be good
and that mentality is
the mental lifestyle is what got me to
where i am
cheers let's move it on joe yeah so uh
sp
let's keep it on mental health actually
so lauren martin up in franklin
tennessee
she uh she practices in that space so
lauren why don't you
joe i need to give you a huge shout out
these little segues are
very very very good i'm impressed all
day yesterday getting to know these
people
yes but just that's one thing but doing
the improv skills of natural things that
are coming out of my mouth and segwaying
i am quite i'm not kidding i'm very
impressed lauren what's up
hi um i want to pivot from therapy so
right now all of my content is branded
under novel
counseling because like novel like new
ways of thinking
i'm considering going to my own name
since i'm the only employee
i'm just wondering if i'm wanting to do
you know more personable content moving
more into education
i'll still have some clients i have some
really good news
yeah i lived this life i went from wine
library tv
i started gary vee and i started
changing the things that came out of my
mouth
while still for a little while selling
plenty of wine
okay the answer is i know it better than
anybody on earth
i really mean that because i was at the
top of my game nobody was doing
influencer marketing and content 2006 78
when i was doing it
i got known as the wine guy i wanted to
talk about business
i lost 80 of my views yeah
i didn't care because you're doing what
you want
and i didn't lose 80 of my business
got it so you'll maintain your business
you'll start adding other components to
your world
and then the world will become your
oyster you
change all your usernames immediately to
your name okay
and make a manifesto video immediately
and saying i'm still doing this
but i'm now in and land this is not ore
everybody
this is not an ore video hey we're a big
believer in the and world
in the therapy world it's a both and
sort of life you know what
that makes a ton of sense to me given
like all my natural nuances so that's
cool to hear
and that's what this is it's not like
you're going into now you talk about jam
or business or whatever you're going to
go into
you're going to talk about both so this
is an and video
now what i'm hearing you could tie it
into the macro of what you do to begin
with
and there it is and everyone's going to
be like congratulations i'm proud of you
girl and all that you'll be on your way
and some people be like oh i don't want
to hear that other stuff and i'll be
fine too
right cool immediately immediately
well you know i'm going to do it tonight
and then my husband's going to be like
of course you're going to stay until
midnight doing all the things
just go to bed um so then i guess with
that
you know i'm wondering so i had that and
then i was curious about the viability
of like the self-guided retreats but i
got your initial reaction on that that
that
like a digital product is really viable
especially in covid world but also doing
things on your own time
um i'm wondering if it makes sense to
sort of since i don't have the product
done i'm in the process of making the
product if i should go ahead and just
start more like an influencer movement
of creating things like i don't know if
people have
considered doing solo retreats or i
think people do it but almost sort of
branding it myself
and then even if people copy it they
copy it i don't give a [ __ ] i just kind
of
yeah it's a good one i want everybody
listening there's nothing in the world
that stops people from copying you
should spend zero seconds on it
it is the greatest waste of time for
entrepreneurs
yeah people worrying about people
copying [ __ ]
stops people from doing [ __ ] when it
didn't matter
well that's like where i've been stuck
because i don't come up with the therapy
models
so i don't want to be accused of
stealing therapy models
but if i'm compiling altogether then
that's my brain you're the dj
you're the dj but make sure the world
knows you're a dj
because otherwise you're millie vanilli
i used to be a radio dj so that's funny
that you see even better
that's what you are you're a dj and you
just have to make sure that everybody
knows that
and that's it and and people value djs
i don't need you to be the creator of it
you being the curator of it is great for
me
so you should own that never hide from
that
awesome let's stay in the medical world
and shift over to milwaukee christopher
do you want to talk about your podiatry
podiatry practice
absolutely yeah by the way chris i'm so
um proud of you for being strategic
enough to take a step backwards for
three steps forward
it is the cliche mistake of almost
everybody
in the kind of businesses that you have
and other doctors and haircuts
many around that business model kudos to
you it's really cool
it's very hard to do for a lot of people
yeah well part of the reason for that is
we lost one of our biggest sources of
new patients with it which is doctor
referrals they're all in the corporate
health care
so we're going up against big goliaths
and we're just trying to figure out how
to
add that third best referral source into
the business so number one is patient
referrals number two would be google
adwords and seo
and then number three used to be doctors
so i'm just looking for that third
strategy and i know digital has to be it
that's where people are that's where
you know the attention is but i don't
really have a good strategy i've done
some you know content i've done a lot of
written content you know just in our
field i've done
some video content but i just feel like
we're not doing
enough and i want to remember just you
know it's funny to jump in here i'm
sorry you want to reach
one last thing is the 40 to 70 year old
female is our demo that's really what
we're looking for
brother one you know what's really cool
about this is um
another actually using lauren as a comp
people like i have this problem like no
no your problem is you haven't dealt
with your childhood
right or like gary i didn't no no you're
i have a major problem with my sink no
you don't you're well
outside your water source is your
problem
the reason i use those two things i want
everybody to hear this chris if you knew
that 90
of your business was how to do pictures
and videos on facebook
you would act differently every day what
i need you to do in these five minutes
and i appreciate the way you just
responded like
i don't like i'm not kidding you you and
then whether you hire people
whether you freelance it whether you
work with an agency
you have to realize that that's exactly
why you had to do it
to your point and i appreciate your
humility you didn't have the strategic
rationale or the burnout or some other
different point
of stepping back you were forced to
because you were live in something else
driving your business
i am never scared because i never
had let anyone have leverage james will
tell you that
he knows the inside of my literally
everybody can leave the company
and they'll be [ __ ] disastrous for an
hour
or a month or a year but i have so much
leverage
and understanding that i'm actually not
vulnerable
you were vulnerable some of you else
here are vulnerable you can't rely
on somebody driving your relationship
with your customer
so this will now make sense which is why
i'm using this it's not the razz
it's to get you fired up to the next
chapter you
have to win instagram and facebook you
you
it's more important than your practice
your ability now it's more important
than balancing your checkbook
it's more important than breathing
[ __ ] oxygen you have to know
what it is and and and it's jason's
answer too jason will get destroyed
in new markets if he doesn't understand
it he will
it's just too much capital up front to
wait for it to happen
unless he raises an ungodly amount of
money or he bleeds all his base business
dollars if he doesn't get good at it at
least adequate
it's not gonna work if you can't create
growth
you know one of the things i've really
enjoyed in working with james dorsey is
he comes from
big holding company agency land where
they are at such scale
they they are about efficiencies
and it's been great for me to learn
because i've always created such growth
but like that's why i'm never like when
you're growing
when you know how to get more business
ironically all the other [ __ ] works
itself
out it's when you stop knowing how to
get business that you have to become a
monster at efficiencies but that's not a
fun game it's depressing
firing people renegotiating like it's
all defense
[ __ ] defense so brother you have to
learn
offense and the offense in your business
is how to acquire customers
and the only way to acquire customers
for all of us including being in small
business land
is social media nobody here is buying a
super bowl commercial
that's great i was putting a little bit
of attention into uh taking your advice
uh hosting the party doing a podcast
called inspiring small business stories
i love that the problem is you need
people to listen
right and if you don't know how to
market the podcast you're going to be
looking at yourself and saying this is
cool for my grandchildren to listen to
one day because it's funny
but it's not driving your business by
the way what you're now you're going
think about how this works i love that
and i'm glad you picked up on that and
by the way you should do that it's gonna
work the problem is if you don't know
how to get people to [ __ ] listen to
it
it's all dead knowing how to do pictures
videos cartoons written words and how to
spend a hundred dollars in media on
linkedin
snapchat facebook twitter tick tock is
everyone's business here
everything's secondary i don't give a
[ __ ] how good the stereo equipment
esther's family has been making for 50
[ __ ] years
if she doesn't know how to get people to
come to the [ __ ] store it's game over
oregon or buy it on.com all of it i
don't
delicious ice cream is subjective
what's not subjective is that people saw
zach and courtney's [ __ ] in their feed
and it's like [ __ ] i'll try it
it's the only thing that matters it's
why i'm completely been obsessed about
it
for a decade not honing any other skill
than trying to become the single best
practitioner at the day trading of media
and creative
on an every second basis and i would
argue
that's why i have just started my
career because i'm now in the place
where i'm
recognized as if and it will only
compound from here
because everyone's about to get educated
in next 10 years that's the only thing
that matters
comma of course your product matters if
tires of course but everyone here's
thing is good enough to build a big
enough business to make everybody here
happy for the rest of their life
they got to get this [ __ ] part right
let's move on a little bit um i've got
and chris the reason i went that route
with you is now anything you've heard
prior or anything that's coming up
i just feel like you're going to take it
an 11 seriousness instead of an eight
got it that's what i'm trying to do here
right like you gotta like get down to
zero
and go oh my god this is actually the
business i'm in that i happen
everybody here is a marketing media
company that happens to do the other
things they say you happen to sell ice
cream
tires you happen to
great you happen to decide to grow a
weird mustache
you happen to oh
gary we've got geo and antonio that are
getting ready to launch an innovation uh
so i figured innovation might be a good
uh change of pace geo
go ahead how are you doing can you hear
us
yes yeah great so uh we're launching a
new product you know going live doing
live streaming
um right now to a multiple destination
is
hard right you have to be platform you
have to be a restream or a switchboard
to do it
so we have developed an app where uh
users can download it
and they can go you can add multiple
social media so what you see here is two
instagram
one facebook but you can do like five
facebook you know uh
seven instagram and then you do a live
when you do a live obviously you're
going live on all the different uh
social media channels
and um uh and then you can actually see
comments coming in from facebook
instagram we are we're also
adding a similar geo to stream yard
right
yes but mobile but app-based i
understand
so we're the first ones in the world
doing that and we're adding linkedin
so we just uh got the approval from
linkedin so it's pretty cool
and we also had a spokesman uh an
influencer
sinbad that was going to be the
spokeswoman you know him you know
you got a comedian yeah yeah i'm 45
years old i know i know no that's i
thought i was going to recently but i
don't know if you knew that he just got
a stroke like last week
i'm so sorry i know it sucks and uh but
he's doing he's doing better
anyway so we wanted to know if this was
your product right this is your app
what how would you mark it you know
anthony is it ready for me to try and
use
it's in the chat window if you want to
take a look we're gonna do a separate
thing
uh joe why don't you set them up with uh
andy and sid
we'll take this offline because i will
absolutely play with it
okay and then i can give you a really
really really really good answer
beautiful awesome why don't we slide
over to hawaii then and uh you already
know zach and courtney but uh zach
go ahead and chime in antonio we'll do
that in the first week of december
we'll have a real meeting
zach courtney great to see you guys
again hi gary you too
um so i mean we're super interested in
what ideas you had for us
from the last call um especially around
like how to provide value as a
sustainable business model for us just
because we're so early on
um i guess a specific question for us is
in terms of branding we have so many
elements going on we have
the story of daniel like daniel's real
life we have the story of the sage which
is going to be like a fictional
character
that we want to use to inspire customers
um
and then we also have like zach and
courtney as the couple high school
sweetheart
starting a business together during
coronavirus so
um and then and then the product itself
right the only organic
made ice cream using local products um
you mean similar to empathy right where
you had me and my origin story
the product itself the story of two
interns that became my partners
the story of the farmers direct to
bottle you mean like every brand in the
world
multiple stories this is this is one big
session of and not ore okay
so i mean we just love it yeah all of it
okay and by the way in the same screen
this post is a beautiful picture of ice
cream the next one's the first time you
guys kissed
the next one is right the next is the
sage the next is a new flavor the next
is it
and watch and listen i know a lot of you
followed me that whole thing i talked
about pcs
post creative strategist the people that
read all the cup that like that's a very
big part of it
you'll see after six months of doing all
of it which one has a little more juice
than others
then you start all four at 25 energy
each
but then four months later it's 60 10
5 22 got it you understand and by the
way
it also ebbs and flows i don't know if
any of you have noticed this
but in the last two weeks my instagram
has taken a different tone
i'm doing a lot more business content
less mindset less motivation
more what i did in 2011 on the next wave
more like here's why spotify is doing
this
paluton and beyond like now my views are
down but i want to for my brand
and for my soul do more business content
because i'm a businessman
and i feel like i've established the
mindset perspective thing the last three
years
we've got that down again now i'm going
to move away from it
and i'm going to be more and you see you
understand
so start at 25 each for those four
stories
and really 20 because leave the last 20
for anything
then you're gonna keep going and going
going and you're gonna ebb and flow and
it's gonna change
for a year maybe it's all about your
relationship but then everyone's tired
they know all your [ __ ] stories
they know about the note in class and
the first kiss and they know
all that [ __ ] but first of all as you
know everybody knows my lemonade stand
and all that i still pound it but you're
gonna ebb and flow it
got it yeah got it okay
um i mean we're trying and by the way
real quick just to make this more
valuable for everybody
one part of your relationship may work
better on youtube the sage might work
better on tick tock
the the flavors might be better on
instagram so there's also
not only are there four strategies and
different flow but your distribution
channels might have different
percentages given
the psychology and the demographics
within that [ __ ]
platform yeah
so it won't be it won't be muddled if we
if we
are talking about there is no muddled
that's a theory
yeah okay you know
and and by the way you're gonna watch
and if you see like people really react
to the beautiful pictures of instagram
high-res
photos of ice cream they're like [ __ ]
we'll do 80 that but like
people fear staying in the same topic
that makes people boring
yeah yeah totally um i guess like what
what ideas did you have for us i mean it
sounded like you had some
some cool ideas i think sampling
is the number one thing that brands
don't do enough of
so anything that can create content so
i'll give an example if you did a thing
on instagram that if you leave a comment
in the first minute
we're gonna pick one person every time
to
send free ice cream to now it's a game
now you see
things like but using sampling as your
as your leverage right
uh make content for us in all your
states and
for the best one for each 50 states
we'll send 50 people
uh five you know cartons of ice cream
now you got content
yeah you know show us your freezer like
just creativity you see where i'm going
using sampling because your product is
delicious
and so giving it away is good for you
yeah because once they taste it they can
come back yeah
which is different than let's say for if
you're selling power tools in barbados
where
they don't need it again that's not good
sampling is not good for toby
if wine sampling was legal because
alcohol you can't give away for free
in new jersey i would constantly do it
yeah so influencer marketing would be
good for us too then
influencer marketing would be 100 very
much
okay so now let's go up to esther
esther and ryan are the last two and
they both have similar conundrums
they're both in the sound space but in
very different reasons esther
uh talk to gary
you're on mute
hi gary so um like trying to
can ryan go because i have so many
things that i want to ask and i'm trying
to see what would be the best use of
race trying to get right we're trying to
get gary out here in 10 minutes but ryan
start us off and ask her hope if we have
enough time we'll come back
all right we'll do i'll try to go as
quick as possible uh gary you used the
analogy earlier about fixing the sink
versus fixing the well
uh before i could use your analogy
i'm trying to fix my well i'm trying to
get out of a career that i've been stuck
in for the last 14 years
and i'm not fancy uh my wife and i we
have three kids we're lower middle class
i don't need to make a ton of money i
just need to make enough
to replace the career patience and
execution every night
feverishness this you know what you know
what one of my great mistakes in my
career was ryan
is when i wrote crush it i talked about
happiness over everything the
opportunity the internet and then i
talked about ryan smith
and i talked about 7pm to two in the
morning
i said if you're all out of options if
you can't get less fancy
if you can't if you've got no other
options you still have 7 p.m to 2 in the
morning with the internet that our
grandparents didn't have
if you were your grandfather you're
stuck
the end this unstuck us
unfortunately for me people manipulated
what i was saying to me saying that
everybody has to work two o'clock in the
morning and burn out which sucks
because i don't want to be associated
with hustle porn but
but here we are and the answer to you is
what i wrote in 2008 and the book came
out no 9 which is
you have to be very strategic about 7 to
2 p.m you have to be patient
because you still want time with the
family you got to take care of your
health you got to be right
but over a five year window because
you're a young man if you if you execute
properly
in that time you have a model to get out
of this situation
otherwise without it you don't and you
go into depression of never getting out
of it
or you just live way shittier you think
you can't leap more humbly
you can do you own a house
you do it's not very fancy but yeah
you could sell it and rent a shitty
place you could
i'm not saying you should i'm not saying
it's fun too you could
but the only thing i know is taking one
step back
even more extremely than you think you
could
or would i get excited about 7 p.m to 2
in the morning
in a balanced way amortized over a long
period of time so it's healthy
around the thing that's going to take
you to the next place
one of the things i don't know if you
saw the email or not
um but one of the things my wife and i
made because we were supposed to go to a
senior bowl to see
was um a poster that said vaynerchuk
jets
and on the other side on the other side
of it it said um
we'll sell our house and move to
chattanooga to work for you
um so my wife's on board like we're
willing to
downsize and and what what do you want
to do
i want to um design
and deliver amazing entertainment
experiences to people
through home theater and audio and video
like that's that's my passion that's
what i've been doing for like 23 years
when you say design
you mean being like the interior
decorator strategist of
what somebody should do for their home
theater uh not necessarily the interior
decorating part but more the system
engineering the technical architecture
of what if nick dio
makes it big one day and it's like i
need this epic theater
and you're like what's your budget he
says 80k you're going to make the best
use of that for the most epic
up-to-date infrastructure 100 percent
esther that's
that bleeds into your world a little huh
yes
for sure um so that's what you want to
do right
can i can i make a huge recommendation
to you
of course that i'm really bullish on
that i'm like praying to god
works because it'll be an amazing case
study and you'll be happy as [ __ ] with
me and forever
i think you should share in long written
posts
and video potentially on linkedin
make pretend scenarios hey guys it's rob
i mean whether this is an article i'll
do my version the videos from hey guys
it's ryan smith
here again with the make pretend
setup show where i take a theoretical
budget
and a theoretical scenario
and i customize that person's home
entertainment experience
here we go on today's episode make
pretend lawyer rick on the upper east
side
has 67 000 for his new hamptons home
he's got two kids that are seven so he
wants that disney plus [ __ ] to be on
fire
let's get into the show all right so i
got sixty seven thousand dollars i got
plenty of room it's not about the
couches
that if you do that on linkedin and
written
or audi or video form
once a week it is my belief in my heart
that something weird will happen and for
everybody who's not following something
weird is
a company is going to reach out to you
and say we want to hire you to do this
and but you have to keep doing this show
because we need more contemporary
marketing
and we think your face matters
or okay bose sees it or or esther sees
or somebody sees it in the business
and goes the other route and makes you
an influencer for their business
i want you to as a doctor writing a
prescription
i want you to do what i just said once a
week on linkedin
and after you do 10 of them i want you
to share the 10th one with me
via email titled here's my 10th one cc
joe q to make sure i don't miss it
and i will give it a little bit of
awareness if i like what you've done
in your first 10. we'll do we'll do
absolutely thank you
you won't anyway ryan we're already
connected on linkedin so i'll make sure
you're
you're up on your 10 posts and gary
it'll be coming hot in your inbox when
it does
uh esther do you have your question
ready yes i do okay fine so benjamin
wanted to say hi to you
it's great to see you again and what did
you want to tell daddy gary who do you
want to be when you're coming
up i am uh
and i'm jumping on the bus my man you
will be
and that he made this for you he wanted
to show
you're very yeah okay so really quickly
very nice so this is one of this is
where i i like lost my train of thought
and i feel like this is like the most
important question that i have because
i have a lot of the solutions of what i
need to do
um but here's my issue you know we have
this brand
right that is a world-class brand you
tell you ask pretty much any audio file
that's serious about audio
and then they'll say lam industries is
like the bentley of audio whatever
fine yeah we operated as like a mom and
pop shop
kind of like the same mentality that
your dad had yet you were
able to scale it and take it to the next
level yes
i was not able to do that within you
know that scope of time whatever just
it's fine everything
happens and it's right time so i feel
like now's my time to launch
um i know that all the things that i
need to do
really i mean yes of course i could do
content myself and hire somebody even
get
interns and you know like that's what i
was actually doing setting up people who
are like
uh interested in high-end audio for the
experience to be with
us they're gonna do free content for us
amazing
but i really need an investor like
there's just no way around it but not
just an
investor i i had a fundraising career
prior to this
if i needed just money i could get money
i need somebody
that's going to be super passionate and
is going to be interested in my father's
life
so the problem with that is and i've
heard this a lot lately in my
you know vc hat on in that life
everybody wants smart strategic money
you know that only really comes in a
partner
right um we're willing to do that i
believe you
i want you to be thinking that way i am
for sure 100
because i feel like we have i always
said that like we're on a gold we're
sitting on a gold mine like we have
brand equity that companies would be
spending
i'm not exactly probably millions of
dollars to get to where we are just with
my father's like name recognition
and where we're at and under it i want
to launch
and i spoke to people before i know how
to do it even though i don't have per se
the
um i have the head for it i don't know
the expertise in terms of running and
operations
you know manufacturing i mean i grew up
with my dad i know certain things
like i would launch little lamb and all
the dealers
every dealer distributor that i spoke to
they love the idea
they want to integrate an amp which
means two of those bulky things in one
right especially for people who are like
i'm not putting this whole freaking
system you know in my two bedroom you
know whatever manhattan apartment
but i want a good stereo and i'm willing
to spend fifty thousand forty thousand
then you have the younger guys
who are you know like i'm sure the guys
who work for you
who could spend 20 30 even 10 000. i
would go as low as like
10 000 entry points and then build them
up to the lam
industries brand right i have it all
planned out i have a business i have it
all written up
my issue is like so do i approach people
that i know from the fundraising world
and try to find a partner that way
do i you know shop it around you know
what i'm saying or do i put it all in
god and say god's gonna send me
well god's undefeated so you can do that
but
if you wanna know what i'm saying of
course i do but if you wanna hedge it a
little bit
i think it's similar to the advice i
gave brian which is i think you
you put it out to the universe i think
sharing that you're you know
that you're looking for a partner in
crime and here's what you're looking for
and i really everyone hear me out tik
tok has crazy organic reach you've all
heard this from nausea for me
linkedin has crazy organic reach if you
go
tell the world that this is happening
once a week for nine weeks in a row on
linkedin
i can't tell you esther how much i
believe that it's going to lead to you
finding someone
yeah but do i really want to like put
out
i hear what you say yes you do i'll tell
you what you do
i'll tell you why because you can
disguise it i understand what you're
saying
you know like like you don't go out you
know like i think you disguise it hey is
there any like
i think you make it look like an
employee or like a partnership or like a
service but really underneath that's
what you're looking for
and you're hoping back to god's hands
that that person
actually is like wait a minute i mean uh
here's a good one
james rossini will tell you the sasha
group uh or even
vayner consulting before at the
precursor to sasha group
and nick dio and joe know that an argent
no
dennis dog we had a great employee he
was doing what joe q and nick and james
were doing
a came a business in one of these
sessions that he really liked
and he left her company to become
partners with that person
so i think you can put it out there not
as a desperation or as a
i need a partner but as a partnership
right and then you could vet it through
the people that come in
right right because like when you speak
about marketing dollars like just the
one idea because of covet we don't go to
movie theaters right
drive-throughs like my dad i always ask
them can i dad can we use your amps for
like music festivals can we
do amps for these like movie theater
things which traditionally before and
the
my dad saw dealer has these crazy
japanese speakers that were used he
answered my question we're doing this
documentary and my dad called the purist
and one of our customers is the c i
mentioned this to the group earlier
is uh the ceo of atlantic records who's
the nicest guy
big audiophile and he has like 1.5
million lp's um he's like
the largest collection of lps so
there's a lot of credit why right right
kellman
yeah craig really well couple things
esther because i know we'll be able to
connect again i have to run because i
can't be
played for them because we have a vote
at one three minutes ago i love
everybody thank you everyone
thank you all right thank you youtube
watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon